hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to welcome to the game
I couldn't stop thinking about this game
I did rag on it quite a bit yesterday I
did but I couldn't stop thinking about
this game there are just some answers
that I need two questions I have so
hello welcome to another adventure where
I lose my mind trying to solve the
mystery of this lady that's been
kidnapped and I'm trying to save her and
failing miserably getting myself
murdered in many ways at the same time
so hi hello welcome it's time to get
started but first but first but first
there's some things that we need to do
the first thing that I need to do is I
need to test how difficult does forcing
the hacks make it you can hack it every
70 seconds now you can force a hack
every 70 seconds now but I want to see
how difficult it makes it because I can
do the minigames I think I can do the
minigames anyway if I just put my mind
do it and then I don't know I don't know
man I don't know I really don't know but
we're gonna get into this right away
we're gonna do this I'm turning up the
volume I'm cranking it up you guys are
gonna get spooked but we're all in this
together so we're gonna we're gonna do
this we're gonna do this yes I'm
starting early because I wanted to get
into it because the sooner I start the
sooner I'll be done the sooner I'll be
done
pro tip don't forget about bookmarks in
the end and so in this first one the
first thing I need to see is can I be
hacked before before 10:20 because
supposedly you can't be randomly hacked
before 10:20 but that doesn't mean that
maybe it doesn't mean that you can't
force acts what am I knew is I'm gonna
Oh shitty dicks oh god I forgot to bring
up my old my list of websites Oh
hang on hey oh god shut up Adam alright
this is going off to a bad start because
I gotta go get this go to the community
hub hang on everybody I got this all
right website times and availability get
those over here alright get this right
here okay that's good
[Music]
right there okay and copy this no no no
no no no no I need to duplicate this
right there and bam okay what I'm doing
is I'm pulling up the list of websites
that are available and at what times so
that way I don't waste any of my time
and I can always see which ones are
available and when they're available so
okay so that's yeah yeah yeah oh shut up
okay we gotta go all right let's go get
our first VPN and then we'll see what's
going on so yes I know welcome back to
the game oh [ __ ] wait a minute did I did
I goof it wait is everyone seeing the
game okay I might have goofed it I
accidentally set a setting that I didn't
set all right I may have to restart hang
on hey hang on I gotta I forgot I
changed something uh uh hey I'll be back
okay on my back my back now I have no
idea if I'm back or not I have no idea
how that's gonna handle that but okay
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back word and then any of
that I have this shirt this shirt is
gonna protect me through any hardship
that I could ever endure nothing will
stand in the way as long as I have this
shirt
and chica bika always being me
protecting me right in my heart we're
gonna get through this game I promise I
swear we're gonna get through this game
I promise we will I hope I hope that
actually fix it if it didn't fix it then
oh well if you guys can see it it's
totally fine yes I'm gonna lock this
shirt on my body it's always gonna be
here forever and ever and ever lock the
goddamn door I can't make any promises
that I'm gonna lock anything I gotta
turn up the volume way high because I
need to be able to hear absolutely
everything I'm gonna get jumpscared like
crazy but I need to hear everything I
don't know why I'm so nervous about this
game yeah you want it maybe if there's
enough demand for it I might I might put
it out for everybody to get but it's a
pretty cool shirt
it's a really cool shirt this was
actually a gift someone gave me from
nutrish oddly enough the dog food
company people all right so let's get
this do that let's lock the door lock oh
we're going out anyway whoops unlock the
door
go and let's see what we got here
doodly-doo to do a little nothing here I
didn't expect there to be anything there
anyway
and I don't expect I'm gonna do much
more than just have two of these bad
boys getting here whoa there we go
easy peasy all right that is definitely
much more randomized than it was before
okay let's do this
all right close that close it lock it
all right so the first thing I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna try to force myself to
get hacked that's the number one that
I'm doing number two though lights
because I don't know if that helps it
all but it seems to have not hurt me so
why not try it okay so I'm gonna get I'm
gonna get one of these two of these
actually I'm gonna go in here I'm gonna
find the websites that are not available
come on buy another one and then buy one
of these all right let's do this
okay so in order to force yourself to
get hacked you can do this every 70
seconds you go to one of the websites
that aren't available black market is
not an available website and then
supposedly you just refresh and
hopefully you don't get hacked or you
get hacked and then you can I don't know
win if that's what we're trying to do
here I'm not a hundred percent sure
about this mmm there is a possibility
that you cannot get hacked before ten
twenty so this might be just a waste of
time hmm heard something there I don't
like that I'm actually gonna do might
try to do this slightly differently I'm
gonna I'm gonna have this open wide now
that's dumb
I have this open narrow yeah like this
yeah it seems like a smarter way to do
things okay web scan
because supposedly
I'm only doing this to test it because
supposedly probe qh h t9 s k g HQ
supposedly this is this makes things
more dangerous this makes people come
after you more which might be bad
because it just accelerates everything
that's going wrong but at the same time
if it can make me get hacks like then i
get more money so that's good lock the
clock lock the clock lock the [ __ ]
we're going and dry no it doesn't seem
like i can i don't think i can actually
be hacked before time so I think that's
a limiting factor
Oh also I think I was wait let me
disconnect from this I was at I'm pretty
sure I left this on while I was away so
that's probably not good we're gonna try
a different one all right that's been
that's been stopped anyway alright keep
going
okay other than that I have kind of
gotten this game down I kind of know and
I kind of understand everything so I'm
pretty sure I'm being able to beat
anything that comes my way no stop this
this is not gonna do anybody any good
hello there we go yeah all right it
doesn't look like I can do anything so I
might as well just try to try to get
things going also still got my note pad
and pencil and for anybody that didn't
see I've got my chica shirt there's
gonna keep me safe through this whole
thing and I'm gonna be totally fine all
right brutal on the ground that is yes
that is yes bilk I wish it wasn't me yes
but it's yes kkx r3h you alright probe
in that one I'm gonna look very closely
because the the address for the second
deep wiki this should be working is it
Oh brutal underground is only available
to set a certain certain time not
available right now I don't think
anybody spawns this early I think it's
actually totally safe all right bug
friendly that is one yes
leave the door open I don't think you
can leave the door open I'm pretty sure
you actually have to close the door but
if I could leave the door open I would
because then that bastard Luke Lucas
could come in here and I could give him
the old what for okay so I've been told
keys are always on the the websites
itself but the link to the next area
that's somewhere else come on now I'm
not seeing anything you guys let me know
if you see something that looks like a
link to another Deep Web but it looks
like this is not it let me try the join
now I'll try though the store the FAQ
all that good stuff all right we found
one crack RP k KX r 3h GW channel 12 6 v
9 go for it alright tell us about you
don't like that yeah alright nothing
nothing nothing
hey we got it alright so p fw p WF is
money one got it alright let's just go
ahead and go for that alright p fw is
money 1 all right so that's easy enough
refresh that you got good it is now 10
20 so we can start to force hacks oh I
don't want to do for this one is I just
want to force myself to get hacked over
and over again so I'm actually gonna go
back before I do this because I'm
testing something because I want to see
how difficult it makes it for me because
it makes it difficult for me then I'm
going to have like I'm gonna have an
understanding that that's not an
appropriate strategy but if there's
still a way to do it this way and get
enough money to carry on with the game
then it should work better for me so I'm
just gonna try to reset this over and
over again I don't think that there was
another WEP on this area I'm pretty sure
anyway eventually I'm gonna get the I'm
gonna get the WPA library yeah this was
the only one
okay but PFW 138 is money one all right
come on hack me hack me do it I'm here
somebody hack me anybody please hack me
I'm here anybody I want to hack me
oh is it not refresh is it just back and
forth maybe that's what it is maybe it's
going back and forth I don't know I
don't know man
no it's the same thing all right I think
it's just the refresh right isn't that
it you guys know what that is right it's
supposed to be just the refresh oops I
don't even know if there was anybody
there yeah hmm did I forget to turn off
the nudity no the turn the nudity is off
it just so happens that apparently old
man but is a perfectly legitimate thing
to show apparently I mean what's so
wrong with old man but says mark quote
that put it in a newspaper write that on
my tombstone
what's wrong with old man nope nope that
way and then that way okay hey look I
got one ooh my windows open that's nice
how much money did I get good money bad
money good money good money good money
okay good money we can go buy another
VPN right now but while that's shipping
let's go ahead and try to get hacked
again because I'd be a little bit longer
we got to wait in between each of those
hacks we have to wait about what is it
like something the order of 70 seconds I
think was the cooldown they said it was
yeah but now I got to be mindful because
my windows open so I think the threats
have begun all right and I got to change
Wi-Fi in about ten minutes I got to
change Wi-Fi I'll go back to the free
one for now or I'll switch over to
another one try to join up on them yeah
the game is very loud yeah you guys
wanted the game to be very loud because
you guys wanted to be able to hear
everything so if I'm gonna get
jumpscared you're gonna get jumpscared
it's just [ __ ] loud that's what you
have to deal with when you're part of
the stream you gotta agree to this you
hit that subscribe button you're in this
with me it's not just me alone and if
I'm gonna be pissed off at something you
guys are gonna be pissed off with me
fair that's fair that is fair it's only
fair all right we're gonna get hacked
again I'm basically just trying to get
as much money as possible in the
beginning of this because the only other
thing that I know how to do is just get
as much money I'm also trying to get
another package I'm pretty sure you
would be able to buy a multiple packages
all at once but honestly who knows
come on Hackney Hackney Hackney hack me
hack me I'm here hack me hack me I'm
here please just hack me already
nope mmm nothing yet that seems like a
bad idea yeah the game is 98% quiet
anyway it's like that's by design it's
designed to be that just so you can just
blast yourself with the whole [ __ ]
of the jump scares that's what it always
is do you guys think I locked the door I
can't remember I don't even know anymore
all right this is a waste of time
all right that seems like a waste of
time I don't know why that's doing it
let me try a different a different
non-working website
all right I need to go back to bug
friendly but I think I'll probably just
go back later
I can go to brutal underground now which
is fun great where we're going
we need to change Wi-Fi soon 100% real
what do we got here
nope I don't see anything for their new
videos okay all right yeesh yeesh yeesh
no good that that is just this is not a
website this is a wallet email
nope seems like there's nothing on here
all right I'm gonna go get my I'm gonna
go get my package be right back
let's hope that there's uh no one
waiting for me down there like a
breather
cuz last time I faced the breather I
died and it didn't work so well but then
again I did push the wrong button so
that was that was entirely my fault
all right let's do this I don't even
know if the VPNs are gonna be worth it
in the long run but yeah I guess they
are I do need to get that motion sensor
and what I need to do is I need to get
an audio alert for the motion sensor
because I didn't pay attention enough to
be able to see it I don't even know what
what it would say if it did I mean I
don't even know if it would warn versus
the police arriving I didn't shut off my
oh I didn't disconnect my Wi-Fi oh oh oh
oh I didn't disconnect my Wi-Fi did I oh
no oh no that's him that's him that's
him oh that's him
I was late on that I was exactly the
same time as I was for every other one
oh you're [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] god dammit [ __ ] god dammit what
what did I do wrong
I hit it exactly when the other times
did [ __ ] it's not like I'm late
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you it's not like
I'm late I did it exactly when every
other time was why does it work on then
and not there I did it exactly at the
same time I wasn't talking I wasn't
moving I didn't if the right mouse
button house is the game [ __ ] me if
you believe that I got [ __ ] by this
stupid game
smash that subscribe button wale on that
like button if you think I got [ __ ]
over [ __ ] one more do you want from me
one more do you want from me game what
more do you want one more cuz it's game
possibly one for me nothing I could do
better there's nothing I could do wrong
there's nothing I could do more there's
nothing I could do less there's nothing
there's nothing there's nothing I did it
as best I could I was totally fine
though it's gonna be like the last one
or something or whatever it's [ __ ]
[ __ ]
I didn't turn the Wi-Fi off cuz I
[ __ ] forgot I was in a hurry it's so
stupid you're supposed to hold it when
he's moving the handle but no no not not
for me not this time no no dodo no it
can't be can't be can't do it won't
allow it can't happen
all right you know what I'm not gonna
try to force any hacks I'm not gonna do
it it's not worth it I'm pretty sure I'm
pretty sure the guy who made the game
didn't want you to play that way I'm
pretty sure he put that in place just to
make it harder for people that try to
force the hacks so I'm not gonna do that
so my experiment is bupkis not doing it
not going for it not doing it so it's
just a bunch of baloney it's just a
bunch of baloney I know you probably
earn lots of money but I just don't want
to deal with the [ __ ] what happens
if I just like perpetually jiggle the
handle just like wiggle wiggle wiggle
and then jiggle jiggle when I'm ready to
jiggle doesn't matter no I'm not gonna
put chat on slow mode I want the chaos I
won't ever get up anything to be
panicking that's what I'm going for
let me disconnect my wife I [ __ ]
[ __ ] pays it ass garbage sit down oh
I can't sit down when I'm holding this
great sit sit I don't know what this is
like this games makes me mad I just want
a consistent experience that's the only
one I enjoy my own out there
I want to enjoy myself I want to have a
fun time playing video games I'm gonna
have great time I want to be grand I
want to just any like a good five
minutes in between deaths just a rant
and rave and scream at the top of my
lungs and then and only then will I be
fine but it's all part of my process
it's all part of my in
like I thought I saw something down
there so all part of my process of how I
game
is how I do good in games guys because
why I can't do anything compared man
that's what I want to see competitive
welcome to the game oh god I'm not gonna
be able to find anything am i no no oh
wait you don't even need to be the near
the walls to see the UH the das coin a
meter in the bottom right if you just
you don't have to place it along to see
it okay so I just need to walk around
till I see that the high end thing okay
that's good red red red I know it's red
yep it's red okay red red red still red
Wow okay great nothing get a whole lot
nothing go whole lot nothing yellow
along this wall great yellow great okay
yeah I'll just keep I'll keep walking
that okay Oh found right here great okay
thank you for being such a cooperative
game love you love you many love much
love please just go it's fine what
everything's fine everyone cooperated
everything's good everything's fine
everything's fine and everyone loves
this I wanna beat this game I'm gonna
beat this game I'm gonna beat it it's
gonna be beat by me the guy who's gonna
beat it I'm gonna beat it I am the guy
who's beating it let's turn out the
lights let's turn out the lights who
tell some spooky stories let's have some
fun let's let's have some fun cuz that's
what we do right when we play games lock
that's what we do I'm gonna make some
twitch emotes just locks that's all we
need anytime we need to clench our bot
holes we need to lock our butt holes
down boy okay so we got the VPN we're on
duty let's put this down here this down
here as well let's get an up let's buy
the sky break let's get
to [ __ ] work boy let's get a work
let's go to work it's time to work man
this game seems a lot like work huh
that's weird
okay okay Ave Satanas not available
right now bathroom cams never available
cotton road not available deep top web
not available dream place not available
on crave yes I believe on crave is
available so this Wi-Fi that I got in
the last one is Bob kiss okay on crave
do not break the nine I will not break
the nine we will not stand for this okay
no no [ __ ] didn't mean to click that in
that yet I didn't even look at the
source code okay we'll go into the
bottom we'll go bottom up alright
can I click on you the gate is open you
have been warned the ground is under our
feet
nope how about the source code nothing
here and nothing here nothing here the
ground is dead under our feet yeah looks
uh looks like it's dead under your feet
yeah you know it looks like it's dead
under your feet
alright WEP scan alright so nothing here
let me go back one hopefully there's
gonna be something on the other page in
the source code but probe SB VF i for SW
for for I will be with awesome okay do
not break the nine nothing clickable
here
nothing clickable here nothing clickable
there no no these are clickable nothing
here is clickable alright look at the
source code go to the top
let's see random site get out no no no
nothing nothing here we go
do not pull can I live by okay that's
the gate okay I didn't see ya no web
besides no nothing looks like nothing
okay looks like there's nothing here I'm
gonna assume that that's true not a
hundred percent sure but I'm gonna
assume it's true also we're cracking
FL ter okay foot doctor foot doctor is a
thing apparently not hundred percent
sure about it but foot doctor theme
seems to be a thing all right oh yeah I
remember foot doctor okay turns me on so
much okay anything in the source code
let's see welcome
all right button fave feet nope nope
none of these are clickable let's go two
favorite feet looks like we've got Wi-Fi
no we don't got we're searching the top
of the Wi-Fi fine then
alright there we go alright so crack
SBV fi4 SW 4i channel 3 902 baby all
right go for it
alright none of these are clickable
nothing here anything in the source code
the answer is a big ol no no no no on
the source code okay home made this is
the game this is a game ladies and
gentlemen I wasn't the thing I was doing
is I was relying too much on the source
code to look for links what I needed to
do last time
was I needed to actually hover over
everything and look for clickable zin
the site because the keys are through
clickable but the source code shows
where the other the other websites might
be NASCAR is the password to this let's
go ahead and switch over to filter go to
NASCAR connect refresh scan that lets
probe the next one
anybody here nobody's here yet okay we
can start we can officially start being
hacked by the way so be ready for that
clench your butt holes for jump-scares
because they are all coming alright
we're going for Suddenlink
let's click on something else did we see
anything with the source code here mmm
the answer is a big old no no okay send
me pics or go to sudden link 990 alright
alright nothing here nothing here that's
not a website that is an email anything
in the source code nope
rub me with feet uh-huh okay I'm a hard
pass
hard pass on that one okay behind the
door my door I don't think there's any
point in checking the the people so long
as the things locked in you're listening
out for it then I guess it really
doesn't matter right okay fortune cookie
that is a thing yes
no not available at this juncture a
happy family who found something crack d
0v v e8 w w8 0 s channel threes six one
three go alright we're gonna we're gonna
change that one in about 15 minutes 15
minutes of game time we're gonna change
over to that one alright fortune cookie
is not available right now happy family
is not available heirloom is available
oh yeah it's the sperm collection I
always read the description of it after
I always get into it also for those who
haven't seen my new chica shirt he's
gonna protect it this isn't for sale
this isn't for sale I'm just showing off
showing off what this is all about okay
good yeah all right good great okay call
condom in discreet packaging great fast
delivery great great great great great
PGP key I'll worry about that later
oh why do I have to go through all that
I saw that no
why do I have to go through all this
[ __ ] rush up rush ah got it
alright anything in the source code
nothing that I can see all orders coming
discrete packaging that's that's handy
dandy oh nice okay great
nothing I see nothing okay let's go to
quality not that I want to spend a ton
of time on this website but I guess I
got to dive deep and be thorough we have
14 das going by the way we have 14 das
going right now Oh God sorry Oh God
is the worst this is the worst web site
I've ever seen is the worst worse web
site I've ever seen alright source code
I don't even think I checked the source
code on the last one and frankly I don't
want to and frankly I'm just going to
take the bet that it's not there you
know if I just have to take a bet on
anything it's gonna be not that all
right I don't see anything here special
orders all right
you hate the jump scares in these types
of games yeah me too I also hate how
frustratingly stupid they are of course
I did did I buy one I don't know if I
bought I don't think I bought one did I
did I buy one I have no idea oh I don't
know if I bought one I don't know if I'm
gonna I bought one I didn't I'm such a
[ __ ] idiot why didn't I do that I've
ruined it I've ruined everything I've
ruined everything now I'm not gonna win
because I didn't get 3.5 da scored no
that's disgusting - it's all disgusting
this whole stream is disgusting smash
that like button if you think this is
the disgusting [ __ ] that you don't want
I don't think the PGP key is gonna do
anything for me but I'm looking anyway
I'm gonna change Wi-Fi in just about
five minutes five minutes okay begin
public PGP key and public PGP key
I highly doubt there's anything here
looks like that's a big ol No okay this
was a waste of my time this is a waste
of mine and everybody's time glad we
went through this this is really good
you know just to be safe I'm gonna go
ahead and switch Wi-Fi right now I don't
even know if it's gonna be the problem
but just in case I don't want to rush
that okay
okay second Wi-Fi up and running
Russia hot burners not available in
loominatee not available leads not
available milk supply I think that's if
I remember correctly that is definitely
an available one okay milkman oh god how
many bodily fluids are we gonna go
through today man
I don't want any of this hmm nothing
clickable there anything in the I do not
water down that's good to know
okay I don't see anything let's go to
more milk pictures that's always handy
dandy huh okay drink up
I won't I nope I don't want to mmm no
I'm good
I'm hard pass okay nothing seems to be
there all right we've got nothing else
here this seems like a big old nope no
beru no okay we got nothing here cool
cool cool cool all right
one less no idea maybe I don't remember
what one list could be Lucas is in here
oh yeah this one source code yep nope
don't like it okay let's just turn off
the let's turn off the computers sound
for now we don't need it I don't think
we need it for anything do we panty
sales should be available no description
needed there whatever oh great all right
cool all right
um nothing clickable here all right
nothing clickable
no that's a wallet that's wallet okay
that's nothing that's an email address
no links there okay I don't I don't see
any other links out so I think this is
just a one page website nothing there
that I could see all right cool we've
got 19 about 20 dotted up to buy another
VPN share your genitals might want to
avoid this one yeah you know what you're
goddamn right but I don't have a choice
do I
all right we need to change Wi-Fi in
about five minutes here in about five
minutes we need to change the Wi-Fi
okay share your generals with me I don't
know don't want to do that I don't like
that idea I don't like the concepts just
don't want any of that
okay there's candy balls that's a email
address not a website yeah okay yeah I
don't see anything here
I don't see anything here it's a long
road to win it's a long road to win in
this game filled with danger and
everything my my goddamn window isn't
even open the Wi-Fi I know the Wi-Fi I
know there's nothing left to hack and
I've been on this one for about ten
minutes so you will die oh this seems
listen I do I don't know well we know
open windows open now now someone
suggested that that might mean that
there's a key on this website so I gotta
find it okay or something important on
this website
okay nothing there nothing there okay
it's getting real it's getting real
finally in the beginning in the
beginning there's like nothing there's
nothing to be done but like once that
windows open shits on [ __ ] is on [ __ ] is
in [ __ ] is ready to go so we gotta we
gotta be on our toes these dudes the
great ascendance
ok I'm out I'm out I'm great
we got a thank you gray guy we got a key
ok so let's write this down let's write
this down where is it
you okay there it is okay five five is
f-d-a 0 F 5 D 6 a 4 5 a got it okay
perfect we've got one yes that's good
we've almost got 25 dos this is good
this is real good okay [ __ ] I wasn't
even on my computer [ __ ]
I'm gonna go ahead and change wi-fi's
after this just to be safe because I
feel like it all right eight six six 107
Jean oh yeah
all right we can buy another VPN or we
can go ahead and buy the sky break you
know what I'm gonna go ahead and say
[ __ ] the VPNs imma say who needs them
I think the VPNs are stupid
I think the VPNs are dumb I think they
don't they don't do any [ __ ] I'm gonna
try to go with just as few VPNs as
possible and I'm gonna go for the other
things besides VPNs like the the WPA
librarians [ __ ] like that I'm gonna
should I save up and try to get the wpa2
or should I try to just go with the WPA
because I don't know how many WPA twos
would be here I know there was tons of
WPAS let's kiss let's go for WPA I think
yeah I'm not gonna go for wpa2 because I
don't even know how to hack a wtpt I -
but I do know how to hack a WPA and I
bet I can win if I just keep going with
that now this may be a stupid thing may
be a stupid thing but you know I'm
pretty stupid all right I'm gonna go
ahead and change the Wi-Fi anyway okay
so I've got that let's disconnect from
there let's change the Wi-Fi I forget
where I put it and put it over here okay
so let's move this to the windowsill
those two honks that was two honks that
was two honks
Lucas is active wait that was two honks
I'm not joking about that that was two
honks door is definitely locked yeah
doors locked
that was two honks so everybody just be
aware shits about to get real
I might just be very quiet for a little
bit that is locked okay let's try that
again
injecting what are you doing it did you
do it
wait is it not Oh oh god damn it are you
kidding me really
all right whatever okay everybody just
pay attention because
I'm gonna go for it I think I'm dead
anyway I thought I had Lee I think dead
okay I wasn't I wasn't even connected to
Wi-Fi why were the police here why is it
superb to me what does it hate me dude I
don't even know dude I don't know I
don't know man I don't know no the game
does not like me okay apparently that
was not one that I could get into I
don't even understand I don't understand
oh the lock yes okay the lock right it's
still locked all right still locked I'm
not looking through that peephole
because because if hmm if if mr. Lukey
man is still there
that's bad then I'm probably you know
I'm on the free Wi-Fi I got to be very
careful here
thought I heard something no connection
there okay sorry I'm I'm just really
paranoid right now I'm really
unbelievably paranoid right now I've
only gotten one key I've got nothing to
my name no one's here
everyone's trying to kill me and I'm
just stuck just stuck forever
I don't think those police were for me
there is a possibility that the police
will come you'll hear the sirens but
they're not for you it doesn't make
sense that they were for me because I
wasn't even connected to Wi-Fi I
remember that I would have forgot oh
we're on the shitty slow Wi-Fi says news
says the Lord God Almighty the door is
locked it is locked
Oh xxx yes please pretty please okay let
me actually get up make sure that okay I
got changed Wi-Fi soon but with 30 I'm
going to get I'm gonna buy on the shadow
market if you let me see I'm gonna buy a
motion sensor okay tour terror oh geez
terrorists the Holy Bible revelations
replant now proverbs prophetic words
against destruction right I don't know
if Lucas needs to honk again before he
comes back or if he can come back at any
time that's what I don't know a nuclear
dream
vision of the future prophetic word
against the New York kid anything in
here
um come on
looks like a big no-no looks like a big
no-no okay looks like a big no-no okay I
think we're fine though I think we're
fine I think we are fine all right I'm
gonna change Wi-Fi just in case hell I
just want to be just in case I don't
want to I don't anything to get in my
way I just in case Oh God alright okay
I've almost reached the end of this so
the Magister I the Magister II what time
is it 11:00 10:00 no no time for that
my motion sensor should be down there
but uh I'm scared scared to go get it
okay whoa oh yeah these guys join the
brother at the last walk anything in
here no enter God I want to get into
this thing okay
can't even enter okay
nothing there
just hold onto your butts guys hold on
your butts it's uh it's about to get
wild cuz I gotta go downstairs and I
know I'm probably gonna get a breather
and yeah it's gonna be bad I don't need
to be as paranoid as I am right now but
I'm just doing it just in case God come
on crack this [ __ ] thing already uh
yeah yeah
okay did that not work no doesn't work
okay those that does not work all right
backdoor hack let's buy another one okay
what do we got we rock that is
definitely a website I know of that one
oh here we go crack okay 3 R 4 9 0 J Y 2
y 4 don't like that I can't see it oh
[ __ ] what channel 11 there we go okay
cracking that one as soon as I'm on this
I'm getting off the Wi-Fi shutting off
my computer I'm going to get the package
yes okay Michael 1 so dev share memory
easy
I got good memory for seven four seven
nine five give me money give me my 50
not thank you
that's good money okay we're gonna
disconnect we're gonna power off power
off we're going to get the back why why
now I guess I'm already on my way out
hate that that's a new sound I hate that
one hate hate that I hate that hate that
I'm gonna get the breather again and I'm
gonna die and then I'm gonna be so
pissed off I'm gonna get the breather
again I mad I might be so pissed off my
my reactions were laser all I'm asking
is that he doesn't be there just please
leave me be leave me be leave me be
breezy man leave me be leave me be
breezy man
I didn't hear anything I didn't hear
anything I'm just doing this as a
precaution
I didn't hear anything
I think it's fine
that's fine okay all right no no don't
pray come on open it get it okay oh okay
I don't know if we're ever gonna need to
go back down there ever again maybe
maybe not maybe not you never know I bet
there's gonna be a war here somewhere
somewhere there's gonna be a war I know
it I know it for a fact okay I don't
know why I'm so nervous right now I
don't know I shouldn't be it shouldn't
be but I am I am I really am I know all
the tricks and yet I'm here in the
middle of it and I don't feel good no I
don't feel good I don't feel confident
please if Lucas is here and shoots me in
the face right here I'm gonna be so
pissed I'm gonna be unbelievably pissed
everything's good everything's good
everything's good okay open this up any
buddy here okay I hated it when that guy
was like in my apartment as soon as I
arrived that was no good okay so we're
gonna put this right here right here
right on the bing-bong er right here
right there perfect perfect now it's so
readily obvious if there's a Lukas on
the way I'm gonna know about it probably
probably maybe it should be right
outside my door what if you that's fine
it's fine it's fine that's totally fine
it's totally legit I didn't lock it we
got it guys we're doing great we're
doing great guys we got a new new Wi-Fi
new Wi-Fi to go to which is good
we got another Wi-Fi on this area that's
good
def chair too okay all right and then
that's Michael Michael one connect easy
connected okay so then let's go to the
other one and let's keep going on this
bad boy yeah I can't believe we have to
get eight of these codes did we find
anything here I don't think we did
because of the power shut off okay okay
injects ns5 k hf e 2 FL 4 okay so that's
working doesn't look like it's working
but it's working come on I went the hell
there we go
okay source code nothing I can see
okay it's almost 11:30 which means it's
almost time for another another thing
that we were going for let's turn our
motion alert there okay it's almost time
for another thing you there I believe is
something we can go to right now yes
this fast Internet
okay anything here nothing that I can
see clickable let's try this you've come
to the wrong place
okay that's fine that's fine totally
fine okay or data your data is available
in two minutes and then Ave Satan is
available in two minutes as well so your
vay your data and Ave Satan are two that
I'm I'm gonna be going for very soon no
I've got a bad feeling - you think
that's your just the only one with a bad
feeling if you got a bad feeling at home
smash the like button slam the like
button if you've got the worst feeling
in the world cuz I know I do
oh my god I do oh alright but one more
minute and then we can go to Ave Satan
which is like yeah all right great
very happy about that nothing on the
floor sensor nothing on the motion
sensor come on come on okay here we go
so this should be open right now
okay reply reply reply reply these are
working right if you know what I mean
apply apply apply apply apply emotion
fly reply reply or they don't know they
don't know replay
heard that that was it's a car car going
by nothing bad
okay look at the source code
Oh someone's there someone's there hello
friend okay
alright someone's there whoo-hoo
someone's there who you already broke
the like well that's
oh come on come on get up get up get up
get up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it didn't work what do you mean there's
only a 75% chance for it to work that's
so stupid
with only 75% chance I'm not gonna peek
outside the door I'm gonna check to see
if it's locked though yep still locked
great okay great okay I didn't see
anything in this one I think there's
still barely no no I just missed the
window for your data I missed the window
for the other one your date is not gonna
come around for another hour
I'm on the free Wi-Fi right now so it's
gonna go a lot slower I need to go
through these again
you go through these again all right no
no no these are definitely no bathroom
cams is definitely no con roads no deep
web is no green places no fortune
cookies yes
fortune cookies available now Wi-Fi am I
on pick another fortune I don't know
what that means
nothing nothing nothing didn't help
anybody
great crack ns5 k hf e 2 FL got it I'm
getting better at that one getting a lot
better that one
come on the free Wi-Fi though I gotta
get what channel was it it was channel 4
okay four go okay I'm a hop onto a
different Wi-Fi just in case
oh my god oh my god oh my god
Oh what even was though this was um
this is Netflix and chill all right this
is Netflix Netflix and chill by myself
your password coming up but us I got
happy family is definitely no hot
burners no Illuminati no leads no it's
sin is a no the butcher's a know your
data god I just missed out on the ones
that I could go to uh it must be your
data your data must be oh hi hello hi
friend okay
must be your data it has to be right it
must be
okay got it
Preda door let's go ahead and connect to
that one
all right Netflix and chill and I can
hop back between that and dev share -
why no no no no no don't trust it
I don't trust it i was on that free
Wi-Fi that might be for me I was on that
free free Wi-Fi
I don't hear anything
outside
it must have been a fluke it must have
been you had to abet the power of two I
it must have not been for me that's my
assumption right okay I'm gonna move
this right to my door I'm gonna move
this right to my door turn on the light
okay we just got a new Wi-Fi we just got
a new Wi-Fi we should be fine everything
should be fine it still says floor 8
hallway even though it's right by my
whatever doesn't matter connect all
right I'm gonna go ahead and look up I'm
gonna order the the other the WPA cuz I
don't know why else I would do anything
all right so I've got pretty much
nothing else besides your data your data
is the only thing and I'm pretty sure
that's got to have a link to the other
wiki because I've been very thorough but
I can't get there until way later so in
that I guess the only thing I can do is
try to get hacked a bunch it's kind of
stupid it's kind of stupid but it's like
the only thing I can I could do but if I
make some money then okay I've got the
second level of WPF I might as well not
be on this Wi-Fi actually you know what
[ __ ] that I'm just going to try to get
this next Wi-Fi
let's go wpa2 all right help let's see
how to do this one hour inject looks
like same thing same thing yeah same
thing okay same thing as WPA one just
probably more intense and takes longer
so since I've got some time might as
well do it now we got one i J x9 9rh n06
for channel 7 foot 40 in OH
oh my god you're [ __ ] kidding me
five
welp alright then let's do this
five it broke it five [ __ ] okay
that's impossible
how would anybody be able to do that
whatever it doesn't matter
doesn't matter okay whoa that's a lot of
them okay
all right in Jack GE v g vb x - 6 k
channel - lets send four so there's no
timer in between them up nope it's
offline I did it too much okay I just
wanted to do that to test out the limits
of it it stopped at four Maxwell's it's
got tastes it's got a soul oh it's gonna
take so long alright inject
ff4 c q r9 j t 7 1 4 do I know any here
do I know no I don't know any of these
here so just stuck with the basic [ __ ]
Wi-Fi oh come on
good god how would you even break into a
WPA did I lock the door
I did I did lock the door alright let's
just try
is ridiculous all right inject hf v 3e k
qk CP 1 4 wait yeah I've got nothing but
time to kill until it rolls around to
the next 30 so might as well right
oh I locked the door alright let me go
ahead and get to the free Wi-Fi try to
get a hack
I don't like just sitting around and do
not like just sitting around I hate it
actually oh [ __ ] it [ __ ] that [ __ ] wpa2
who would even what what would be the
benefit there is no benefit to that god
if it takes as many as WPA 1 in that it
took 600 it would take you the whole
goddamn game just to get to that point
that's so [ __ ] whatever whatever
whatever whatever 6 p 0i t v-- u 2 + r 4
40 okay I'm a salty monkey monkey
I know I'm probably screwed I'm aware of
this I probably did that too many oh
yeah I [ __ ] it god damn it of course I
did I didn't mean to do that
I'm just getting impatient now get
flustered I'm getting impatient I don't
know what I'm doing I'm just going too
fast all right this one's I'm gonna get
this one why am I even bothering going
to these different wi-fi's anyway I had
to back there that were perfectly
adequate come on hack be already Jesus
oh [ __ ] it I'm going back to the other
ones [ __ ] it [ __ ] it [ __ ] this [ __ ] it
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] it was I over here was
it even on the bed I don't remember if
it was on the bed oh no it was not it
was not even on the bed where was it was
it by the window probably by the window
I'm fine I'm fine everybody fat cloud I
didn't connect a fat cloud there we go
let's go to Netflix and chill red tour
connect that's what I wanted oh there's
a big mary ii or v uu w p h z WP
c.j kill T G okay oh no u t c q b ut c q
me goddammit
oh hi hello hi friend
okay I'll stare at the wall for a bit
he's not happy with what I was doing
he's not happy not happy with that I
don't have access to the drone site
right now do you see the drone site in
my list it's not there so there's no
point so shut up
oh god he's still there good yeah he was
not happy with what I was doing so I and
frankly I can't blame him so I'm not
gonna I gotta do that it's almost time
if this almost sounds fourteen more
minutes for it there's nothing else that
I can do I don't have any other ones
that are unlocked at a time besides your
data and it's because that [ __ ]
[ __ ] Lucas messed with me I wasn't
able to get here so I might as well I
guess try to I don't and no actually I
don't even think there are any more WPA
2's at this one I think it's all gone I
know I could buy the motion alert like
the the audio alert but oh there's one
okay inject IJ x 9 r rh n 0 6 r 7 with
for guess i might as well try that i
just have a bad feeling something's
gonna coincide with all the wrong
timings in the world I know I'm boned I
know I know I'm boned I just got to get
to this one website now I mean I'm
almost positive it has to be there there
was nowhere else that had any other
things
I
[ __ ] wpa2 [ __ ] it [ __ ] WPA - what can I
even do in the meantime
okay I'm gonna do something that's gonna
be real risky but I I feel like I have
to I'm gonna get another motion sensor
I'm again another motion sensor I'm
gonna go get it if the the douche
breather wants to [ __ ] with me then
that's fine but I'm gonna do this
disconnect power off because if I have
to motion sensors and maybe I'll have a
better shot at it but I don't know also
this is gonna kill enough time that I
can then get to that website if I do
make it back successfully so this is
kind of a go-for-broke [ __ ] thing
but uh cuz I don't want to stand around
I feel even worse standing around than I
do going out in the alley so I if I had
to pick one I'll choose this yeah I know
I know it's bad I know I going out after
midnight I know it's bad I know it's bad
I know it's real bad didn't hear
anything didn't hear anything I didn't
hear anything
I think I'm fine I think I'm fine I
think I'm fine are you guys enjoying me
of my stupid decisions are you guys
enjoying my horrible stupid decisions
well just subscribe and you can get my
horrible stupid decisions every day hey
how about that was that a body I thought
I saw a body huh if you want to see more
of my cool amazing terrible decisions
check out all the other videos that I've
done they're real stupid just like me
and I know Lucas is probably gonna be up
there this is probably where I die de
Lucas this is almost definitely where I
die de Lucas Luke is gonna be there I
know he's gonna be there he's gonna oh
god I have a sound represent gonna be
there oh no oh God
he's absolutely 100% absolutely gonna be
there how would you even prevent it
can I go in here can I prevent it shut
up
oh the power was off does that bode well
for me yep okay the power went off while
I was away perfect good to frabjous day
Callooh Callay hello no one's here good
where should I put this one guys where
should I put it
I'm so excited guys where should I put
it outside on the balcony perfect maybe
I could just get a nice breather also
what's the benefit of going over this
way
I I honestly don't know what what going
up here would do for me you know what I
mean oh yeah I can't go up any farther I
can only go to here I could put this
here but then again what would be the
benefit of this right I don't know I
don't know man
I don't know where else to put this
maybe outside my window might be nice
uh-uh
I don't know don't know must be
something exciting I mean I've got one
in the hallway maybe one out here in the
stairwell make sense to me
all right that's the best that I can
think right now unless you guys got a
better idea then whoo boy I don't know
it I don't know what the better idea is
but also I need to get an audio alert
for that too okay let's boot her back up
let's see if it's time I bet it is time
all right let's get back on Netflix and
chill actually let's go to the other one
let's go to dev share - lets go to dev
share - please okay we're going to be
sure to like one connect all right let's
go home all right it is almost time all
that and it's only almost time okay come
on come on come on come on oh the door
yeah the door the door the door the door
lock the door that's important hmm
lock lock of the hawk the door how do I
keep forgetting that you think that I
wouldn't forget that okay here we go
it's got to be in here right it's got to
be in here if it's not in here then I
refuse everything I'm gonna Oh God
your data have been encrypted haha if
you need your data pay that to that I
don't trust that at all
no it's fine
god damn it there's nothing here this
was a waste it's gotta be in one of the
other ones god dammit god dammit dammit
dammit [ __ ] where I looked in everything
I looked in everything I looked into
everything I don't know might have been
the sperm collection one I locked the
door I locked the door I locked it I
locked it oh boy oh boy
there's no
there's no drone website there's none I
gotta go back I guess I don't know and
every single one of these that here oh
whoa wait no that is it wait that's it
wait this is it this [ __ ] copy this is
it this is it
wait this is it put an H at the
beginning of that go wait bookmark this
this is it this is the other wiki yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes oh okay this
doesn't mean anything amazing but it
means that I've got more stuff I'm in
the second wiki huh oh oh hell yeah hell
yeah hell yeah hell yeah hell yeah okay
all right hell yeah okay
all right I'm gonna buy an audio alert
I'm gonna buy an audio alert for my
motion sensors whoa the [ __ ] I guess
that's good okay I got it
yes hype hype hype we made progress this
is the first time we've made progress
ever in the history of ever
we've never made progress like this I
don't I don't know how I missed it this
is like that I think that website just
creeped me out so I wanted to get out of
it as quickly as possible but this is
good this is good this is good this is
good bathroom
oh no not not there not there that I got
to make that no ah deep wookie - how do
I make this my home page
god dammit cleaning services that is a1
okay okay yeah cleanup great
no nothing that I can see burial no
burial of a body no nothing that I can
see nothing I can see I got to
eventually get another wpa2 Wi-Fi I'm
gonna have to do that
cuz I I don't want to bounce between
these too much it's it's not gonna be
the best for me because I made that
mistake of hanging on these guys too
long before so not gonna do that
alright alright doesn't hear in fact you
know what
just as a preventative I'm gonna do that
right now just because I am very
paranoid and I don't want I haven't gone
outside yet I haven't put it outside yet
so we're just gonna go outside we're
gonna use the free Wi-Fi to get to a WPA
actually we should probably just do the
whole shebang we should do WP first then
WPA then do all the things and just get
it now that we've got a potential year
we've got about three hours with which
to do it so I don't want to waste any
second of that time you know what I mean
that's fine it's fine
yeah okay let's go WP EP first scan it's
gonna free Wi-Fi let's go to d2 are you
some do you huh game oh you some huh
[Music]
easy baby yes alright probe Jan HS g v
e6 8qs 1000 please all right corpses for
sale that's not one cry [ __ ] that is
one we should get an audio alert from
anything that we got going on here so
you'd think you'd think that would be a
thing you think that would be a thing
you think of do you think bing-bong oh
hell yeah baby oh that's our second key
that's our second key 2 2 4 1 0 3 e 3 8
9 b d e got it second key on route
alright let's open her back up go back
home alright we've got our second key
we've got an open port let's crack JN h
SG v e6 8q on channel 7 port 4 6 6
crackit alright as soon as that's done
we go at god I keep doing that I keep
going home instead of the the other wiki
okay and the audio is on so we would
hear something okay Dido is not
something family drug shop not something
father Donald no flesh trade no forgive
me yes that is one I believe I believe
cheese okay Wi-Fi a f18 5 D is cheese
cheese connect all right we're connected
to that let's refresh now we're gonna go
to WPA lots to do lots to do last dude
no I would have gotten a motion alert
he's not here he's not here I am the
dark I am on the dark web letting the
girl die that's not good I like it up
the butt IRB furry porn okay oh yeah
nothing too amazing there all right in
Jax q g9 t 9j z e9 v k5 k channel 5
let's put 35 into that okay
ah I am a [ __ ] for woo [ __ ] for likes
and subs
got nothing there okay no I went home
again god I keep doing that
God I stop doing that okay no going home
no going home there's no home for me
here it's all about this baby oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] you okay all right it's fine just
go for it faster faster we do this the
easier it is easy peasy easy peasy not a
problem not a problem not a problem not
a problem not a problem not a problem
not a problem not a problem
oh hi okay that's a problem I'm just
gonna lock my door take a long time
locking my door so scary why are you
here you don't need you don't need to be
here the [ __ ] was that the [ __ ] was that
my balcony I heard a metal bowl I don't
like that okay uh oh good it
disconnected my Wi-Fi okay geez continue
go please okay I think I'm fine I think
I got my motion detectors those should
protect me probably okay game Kat is not
one hack the fryer not one Hale said no
hidden pleasures is one yes I'm not I'm
not boned I got this I got this I got
this I got this I got this
okay I don't know where anything would
be on here
um post a sale yeah I don't I don't know
why we're on this website there would be
anything but as well try I got to get
quicker on this this next Wi-Fi cuz if I
stay here too long I'm not gonna be okay
that's nothing
if I take too long I'm just gonna die
too police last thing I want
okay let's try any of these bases
there's too many pages on this one too
many pages I'm not gonna hide I'm not
gonna hide there's not the hide from I
didn't get any alert did I or whatever I
don't think there's anything yeah I
don't think there would be anything on
these trim message did I lock the door
yeah I locked the door yeah I liked it I
liked it I remember I took a long time
to lock it there I locked it I locked it
I'm not boned
I'm not boned I'm totally fine totally
fine everything's fine everything's fine
we got two keys we're doing great
okay that's nothing all these seem to be
broken this whole website seems to be
just broken but that's fine I'm just
trying to be thorough everything's good
yeah I don't think there's anything else
besides like bye that would be the only
other thing that I could click on in
this page
by another uh backdoor hack let's go by
I'm not gonna get anything else I'm not
going outside ever again oh here we go
anything here
lot number do you know I don't think
this is gonna go anywhere yeah I'm just
never going the alley again I'm just not
like I will not do it okay yeah there's
nothing there okay don't go home go too
deep Wicky I don't like being on this
wife I do yeah if it's a single honk
it's fine
single honks are fine double still
should be fine
[Music]
l ji x ay e LG x AE r t g v r t GV s z q
c s z QC o this is sounded similar in my
head in my head they sounded very very
similar no motion alerts no nothing
we're good we're good okay you love cats
my home my cats my cats
about this oh the police are gonna be
coming for me soon if I don't get to it
this next Wi-Fi anyone here anyone here
no clicking clicky clicky clicky clicky
clicky clicky clicky clicky clicky
clicky clicky nothing there nothing here
I don't think there would be yeah I
don't think there's anything here looks
like a big ol no no I god I went home
again don't go too deep wiki - please
okay here please just crack it crack it
please
there we go okay thank you alright crack
qg 9 9 jz e 9 v k channel 5 channel 5
okay that's being cracked so that should
be good keepsake is a thing okay mark
that don't like that oh I don't like
that at all ally is Mark I do not like
that Wow that that is I don't like that
don't nope don't like that nope don't do
not like that I don't like that alright
that was nothing must not be available
at this time okay that's something I do
not like okay alright no boy alright but
we're on the new Wi-Fi we can then scan
again we can get moving on the next one
all right mutilation mutilation is a
thing apparently okay uh inject HH HH VI
oh this one's not a fun website TZ I
think I've been here before
let's try 35 again that was a good one
all right who's watching who's watching
who's watching watching watching no
one's watching
I was watching that's the same thing so
far so good so far so good so far so
good
ok following yeah we're gonna be on this
Wi-Fi for a good bit make sure I change
by 1:30
it's token I don't have a token
you guys what I did the motion sensor
cough I didn't see anything [ __ ] did I
miss the motion sensor how the [ __ ] did
I miss it I hate life I hate this game
it's so stupid why would it be a
delicate butterflies whisper why isn't
they learn a big old Hong Kong Hong Kong
let go get your [ __ ] head out of your
ass you [ __ ] just doing
shut up why would it just not be the
thing why would it feel why wouldn't it
just be a big old brand brand what's the
point of pain das going if it doesn't
[ __ ] alert me ah kill me kill me now
my shirt didn't work my chica sir didn't
protect me
[Music]
I did buy the alert I bought it
you guys saw me buy it you guys saw me
buy
[Music]
alright I'm done I'm done with this game
I'm done with this game you warned me
you're on a delay you guys see this at
like a 10 to 15 second delay so by the
time you tell me something it's I'm
already dead [ __ ]
alright well anyway thank you everybody
so much for joining me
if you think that I got boned over in a
million ways like button destroy that
like button
annihilate that like button but if you'd
like to quit see cool other videos that
I do be sure to subscribe for more
awesome videos that I make I make a
video every day 11 a.m. Pacific Standard
Time or I livestream depending on my
mood and what I want to do ah yeah so
thank you everybody so much for watching
check out all the other videos I've got
if you want to see more scary games I
play a ton of these if you want to see
welcome to the game part 1 check that
out as well that's all my channel just
search for it or I believe if there's a
playlist for it but thank you everybody
so much for watching I need a break
before I get back to this I'm getting
good at the game it's just like my
problem is I have to talk while I'm
recording this so me talking means I
can't hear [ __ ] and me I'm not paying
attention meaning me I'm not do good
what I was did I not by the alert
what is the alert even sound like I
don't know anyway I may or may not be
streaming on Twitch today if you guys
want to catch some more casual stuff
just me playing some games but I find
fun you can follow me over on twitch TV
slash markiplier the only way to know if
I'm streaming because I don't have a
regular schedule is to either subscribe
here
click the bell for notifications or on
Twitch hit follow and enable
notifications I scream randomly at all
times in sometimes it games like this
sometimes this game is just like
for tonight farm together thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
for joining me on this stream hope you
guys have a lovely night I'm out I'm
gonna go cry I'm gonna cry man go cry so
thanks again everybody and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
bye guys bye